boxing it's exhibition it's like a
sparring match you listen you i'm out
you ain't getting my money no you're not
paying for it i'd rather pay for a real
fight
yeah that's crazy i'm saying this i'd
rather pay for a real fight and
jake paul been asking because i know
it's real than this
weird kind of sparring with no head gear
yeah we're going to hear you that's the
way it's awesome yeah but manny's not
going to come
listen if that's a real fight if it was
real fight like
keith thurman you crazy you think ryan
garcia gets out yeah
right he get his head knocked off but
again we didn't haven't seen manny in
two years brenden
so okay what makes these guys want to go
after these types of dudes like what
makes ryan want to go
that's a legend i want to fight manny
yeah like but like
but you guys are saying he's not he he
doesn't have a chance
i don't think right if he's real
he's like it could be a gentleman's back
it's a win-win situation for ryan if you
lose are you lost in one of the groups
he gets flatlined yeah if that's true
yeah but i don't think if he gets nate
robinson flat line
he's not man panic back y'all ain't
gonna flatline ryan garcia shut up
that's juan marquette
marquez yeah he flatlined manny pacquiao
i mean greatest knockout of our time
yeah but that was two like technical
technical like fighters manny pacquiao
is like past his prime we both can admit
ryan garcia his last fight he beat keith
thurman
keith thurman that's insane
bring up keith thurman's resume
it that's such a stupid comment keith
[ __ ] he ran he run it he's running for
my man earl spence
okay he's not signing the fight to
terrance crawford i get it he beat
sean porter he beat danny garcia garcia
not legit
you saw what you're saying remember we
talked about that you said let's let's
go over this okay
so i beat danny garcia who's a
[ __ ] and earl spencer
sean porter and okay but hold on hold on
that was
that was 30 you know until he lost to
manny pacquiao
yeah wait let's just go down you're
talking about you're talking about a
multiple division
world champion multiple different is he
better than aerospace
i don't know i i don't think he's better
than real okay okay but remember keith
also
was injured yeah but earl space coming
off and got me an
almost fatal car crash yeah but
that's different the injury that uh
thurman had terminated yeah
on his shoulder surgery yeah but that's
a common that's what you do
sean porter and danny garcia back to
back okay all right whatever
but also for a world title he's got to
give that man you can't say he's not
[ __ ] you're right you're right you're
right okay i'm saying manny pacquiao
that fight by the way
honestly that wasn't the key thurman i
know like manny pacquiao dismantled it
well that's what he delivered
he delivered yeah you're right am i
right let me know what i'm crazy
but i'm saying i'm but this is what i'm
saying right here we haven't seen manny
pacquiao in two years
okay 2019
all right this guy he's he's been
fighting like manny pacquiao needs
fights
he's old now he can't do that one year
late like remember what connor said
like you just can't dive back into
something and then like yo you think
like these young guys
these young bro ryan garcia is a young
dog you think he
like many manny pacquiao's gonna go in
there and just like dismantle yeah
yeah okay so
let's let's look his last legend like he
didn't lose to jeff horn the teacher he
didn't lose that fight in australia
they robbed him yeah so his last real
loss was to admit uh floyd mayweather
granted he had one arm in that fight
here you go with these excuses that
floyd said y'all was going to go with
okay i watched that fight okay those are
facts how was that fix
he had one arm he couldn't he could've
posted on the fight but many
many could have postponed that fight i
think how mad everybody had been if he
postponed that fight
again floyd said it either way even with
two good ones i'm not making
excuses yeah maybe even with two arms
it'd been a better fight i don't know if
manny wins but
i want my [ __ ] money back that fight
was awful yeah
if you were like i was there if they
would have told us hey you know manny
has one arm going this fight i'm like
i'm not paying for that
yeah of course he's gonna you should be
mad at me he lied to the public i know
well there pete there was a lawsuit
against him for it uh-huh
damn okay okay so but besides floyd then
he gets knocked out by
like tko by juan manuel marquette dude
thousand two on twelve bubba
he he beat chris algieri he's no punk
floyd with one arm dude beat timothy
bradley a lot of people don't think you
won that fight
either way he won that fight timothy
bradley jesse vargas no punk jeff horn
beat him
dude matissi's no punk at all that is
true beat your boy adrian
let's go through his last three fights
okay compared to ryan garcia's last
three fights okay
batisi broner keith thurman
okay get the [ __ ] out of my face that's
insane that matisse is the one i respect
for real
dude he knocked him out he's not what
about but broner's no punk
he's so talented ever since he's got a
head case ever since he got knocked out
by marco's madonna he don't throw any
punches now let's
look at ryan garcia's last three okay
let's go ahead luke campbell
you mostly you've just heard of luke
campbell if you're not
francisco i will know that
romero okay there you go
but look look look i get it he's not
fighting anyone but look at how he's
knocking him out
if they're not if this is a mismatch i
don't want to see any rounds
first round knockout first round
knockout seven round knockout
second round knockout like if they don't
belong in the ring with you
knock him out that's what he's doing i
agree
and that's what young prospects do thank
you you see what i'm saying some
young prospects that get a night where
he's like oh he didn't look good and he
fought a tomato candy i didn't think he
looked good against luke campbell
i think because he got knocked down the
second round well he always fights with
his chin up so eventually someone's
going to what do you think's going to
happen if manny pacquiao lands out many
packs
yeah he can't man pacquiao knocks dudes
out bro do you think that'll be
competitive i think so you think so i
don't think it's like going to be a
tko if it's a real fight i think man it
would stop him but if it's competitive
then that's why they should probably
sanction it if it was something like
crazy like you know
i'm again like i understand you're
saying that skeptical hypo eyes that's
not sanctioned
that's weird man you're talking about
two i mean they're in there
they're doing they did it yeah why is it
not real because you promote you said
boxing is ran by promotional companies
crazy so yeah i don't want to see the
it's not real [ __ ] it don't make way
more money if it was
an actual boxing that win
let's say ryan garcia wins by decision
no one respects that how it's not real
one of the belts aren't on the line it's
not 12 rounds manny pacquiao
put your big boy boots on fight a real
fight manny pacquiao probably is like
not been off for two years this young
buck is knocking everyone out give me
someone easy first then i'll probably no
wait man
do you manny [ __ ] packed out i hear
you keep saying that he's been awesome
i guess ryan girl the greatest to ever
do against ryan garcia
right now yeah hold on hold on he can do
it i believe it i believe in man no no
let me just set this let me
set the plate for brendan and listen
what he's saying adrian brady pacquiao
keith
his last three wins matinee you're
telling me those yeah you're telling me
right now adrian broner wouldn't beat
ryan garcia
no what adrian brown not beat you you
believe you believe in writing and i
love adrian i age you believe in him a
lot
no i don't you believe in reinger he get
you beats matissi
yeah no no that's a competitive fight
it's a close fight but even with that
that says a lot about ryan you
yeah you believe a ton and right tank
knocks out ryan
danny haney beats ryan in the boxing
match tofido lopez
kills ryan i don't think ryan is a great
fighter i'm just saying
manny pacquiao is oh he's 40 what 42 41.
he's still killing it okay been on for
two years you haven't heard from manny
pacquiao so the fact that he's off for
two years
fighting a young buck who's like
knocking everyone out all right
full of confidence you think he's to go
in there and just like yo
[ __ ] with manny pacquiao he's going
to kill manny no i got a chance
all right from a two year from a
two-year break not a chance okay
all right no chance because how how long
did mary take off when he beat keith
thurman
go back to that it wasn't that long dude
you're talking about because he fought
he fought his thurman he fought adrian
broner that same year
look at that same year so hard but he
took four years off
when he take four years off i'm sorry he
took how long off he didn't take he took
a long time off after matissee
he took a yeah he took a year off after
the jeff horn
lost really won that fight and then
fought matisse after a year off and beat
him stopped him in seven rounds doug
for a world title okay here hold on
here's the thing and then a year later
okay fought so he's having a long layoff
years off all right
took a year off then fight adrian broner
beat him took another
you know took a hot second off then beat
keith thurman ken let me counter that
he's only 40 by the way okay he's four
okay any small 40. he's a small 40.
let's let's just
i love how you bro he take a year off
matisse he fought matisse
at a welterweight like he's a bigger
matisse is a small guy
and he fights naturally at 140. he
fought manny pacquiao at 147
and let's be honest he comes forward and
he's just a heavy-handed and he's slow
manny pacquiao dismantled that style any
day of the week
so that year off can be it comes with
the little complex
mysterious ways that okay you don't see
that now
the next fight adrian broner that was a
great fight for
manny pacquiao he just over dismantled
him because he's in rhythm now
boom then he fights keith thurman later
on that year in rhythm
and kills him so you mean tell me he's
not in rhythm so you think he's off
really bro he's off
two years okay and ryan garcia you we
just knock out knockout knockout
he's full of confidence he wants this i
see what he's saying
he struggled luke campbell yeah but
you're telling me if
manny doesn't hit him with the same shot
he's you think he's getting up
you don't think manny pacquiao hits
harder than luke he does but that's what
the gym is for now he knows where i can
get touched at now
and he saw pause just like luke campbell
he's oh i'm gonna be ready for that shot
and and and let's uh luke campbell's way
taller
than manny pacquiao so yeah maybe i was
faster better footwork
yeah better boxer who has whoever
ryan garcia will have more reach he's
developing a jab i like what i saw later
rounds listen that's the heart of a
champion he got knocked down in the
second round he could have got up
he got back up and stopped the guy and i
bet it against him i was like oh i see
something but even you're skeptical of
the stop
i'm not skeptical of the stop but manny
pacquiao reached manly he has small arms
why wouldn't it pop up right away either
67 inches
and then go to ryan garcia and go 70.
not crazy
okay look at that look at the height
look at the height uh chin
five five go to that's what that's what
he's five five yeah this one man it's
tiny this one manny
pac-man that's what he does okay five
ten he's five times garcia the height
the tallest guy he fought
was uh what's the guy named who patted
his gloves i can't think of uh his name
um margarito margarito the tallest guy
and ryan and he comes in he shields up
and what do you do to margarita and he
did he what are you doing margarita okay
he killed what are you doing
he killed margarita pieced him up
exactly
ryan garcia is a boxer he's a mover he
comes forward
he throws he's way faster who's faster
man manny
manny pacquiao or ryan garcia manny
pacquiao
brandon 100
inside the ring now on youtube and clips
on instagram probably ryan garcia my
garcia is lightning fast in the ring
first round knockout first round
knockout against nobody i don't give a
[ __ ] dude
he's fighting nobody's all right all
right the great manny pacquiao
i'm i just want you to hear what you're
saying one time one time you're saying
uh
manny pacquiao is fast from ryan gershy
okay inside the ring okay inside three
again he his last fight was keeping
keith sermon i hear what you're saying
right now you don't think keith
thurman beats luke campbell easy yes
easy yes
you think luke campbell beats uh porter
no you think luke campbell beats adrian
broner
good fight but look what he did there
but brendan he's listening he's
listening luke campbell is a small guy
he listen guys that's like 147. walk
away sorry you go down a little bit
name someone in their weight class i'm
saying man okay all right
to just discount manny pacquiao i'm not
discounting them but you're discounting
ryan garcia like
i'm just not sold on him yet to fight
these big boys
but but as a as a he has a belt well him
and devin healy have the same there's a
million
listen you know how will you knock
someone out everybody getting belts you
know when you knock someone out and
everyone is like you on that cloud line
you want to call out he called out tank
i can't get tank i want manny pacquiao
manny pacquiao i was like why couldn't
he get tanked well because promotion
again promotional no adria or tank
wanted the fight yeah but yeah right
it's easy work his promotional easy work
his promotional company you know why
you know why they they said they said
that's for tank
davis hey what kill him destroy him i
know what about lopez
he'll kill me nobody's talking about
lopez well tank's talking about he
tanked this because well that makes
sense yeah tango lopez makes sense david
wants come get it devin healy want that
smoke you think devin haney beats tank
hell no no way but it was oh so can i
tell you and lopez was on food
star i want to hear lopez was on food
truck and he was like tanks easy work
man
which is well you know they grew up and
they grew up in the jet yeah
but tank took it easy on uh uh lopez
because you know he's younger than uh
lopez said he be
beat him up his clips online that tank
is he's getting out but let me can i
tell you a story once
here man so i saw devin healy right
so he comes in haney
there's no elements hey we pulled devin
they've been hanging right
now definitely he's a [ __ ] let's
do real quick before your story okay
devin haney lopez tank okay garcia yeah
who has the least skill out of those
four
that's not fair though no i'm just
saying who has least skill
of course you're gonna say ryan garcia
but there you go oh but but
now hold on it's not fair now but why is
it not fair garcia has more fights than
lopez professionally
can okay listen you're putting in these
top these guys are beasts
they're naturally gifted this guy that's
who ryan wants to fight yeah
now if you come to me and go reins fight
another prospect i'm signing with ryan
when we talk about the creme de la creme
ryan's just not there yet
right they want to push him like he is
but ryan just got with a professional
team
canelo he's been training in victorville
in a garage that's how he blew up
he doesn't have like his skill where he
doesn't have the the background as these
amateur fighters like my fault
no i get that i get what you're saying
but i'm saying ryan garcia and manny
pacquiao
and he's on cloud nine and with a real
team we'll see okay
put a grand on it on what put a ground
on ryan garcia
oh pacquiao i'll put that in crazy i'll
put that up
i will put that up bring it now brenden
if it's a real fight now if it's like on
thriller or with a trill
[Applause]
no if it's a legit sanction fight yeah
i'll bet you that all right we're back
all right
now i wanna i don't wanna just hope is
like this exhibition don't go through
i'm like yo fight for real for real yeah
i need a real well you gonna better
grant a hundred percent he must
he tripping really i guarantee you
ryan garcia over manny pacquiao over
manny pacquiao in a real fight who's
been off for two years you're insane
yes yes a hundred percent a healthy
manny pacquiao this guy just got one
wild
guy this guy just fought in a
championship fight
and he and granny he didn't go to the
championship great
he didn't look great he came back and
knocked him out yeah he didn't look it
was
you didn't watch him like oh that's the
next big thing
what did he show you he showed you heart
confidence and he showed you power in
the late rounds
that's i saw a slow left hook you know
that left hook was
so loud you said it was fast when you
were you i didn't i know i was like that
left hook is not hitting
which one we watched i was like that
left hook when he knocked him off body
shot was dope okay but up when he kept
going up top
it was not there it would be better it'd
be there for
manny pacquiao hey look let me tell you
a story real quick and i'm gonna tell
you
we'll get off it so yeah let's hear it
devon you know so tank was it was wasn't
all in the doghouse tank was running
through these guys
tell the listener what the dog house is
at floyd so floyd mayweather's boxing
gym
uh the dog house is it was sparring
matched with like unlimited time there's
no time so yeah
they find out like the heart of the
heart buddy yeah so it's like mostly
black
african-american fighters we're around
the ring we beat like this on the side
it's so intense it's so intense so
they're like that's me anxiety watching
we talk we talk [ __ ] so you will talk
[ __ ] till you like get you off the game
trying to break are you talking
about i'm trying to break it down yeah
yeah okay okay so it was the day where
tank was just like
breaking one everyone down yeah and he
was like man no one won a spark tank
floyd was with uh devin at the time he
and
they called him and it was like yo uh
hey man tank talking [ __ ] he was like no
one wants to spar him in his weight
class and floyd's like i got someone in
the car with me right now
and then uh and then so he was like you
went to the gym pulled up to the gym
now devin henry dad is the real legit
dude he's a real one like a real
hardcore he was like man
hey ain't gonna be no sparring we
talking my dog house put money up
so they was like oh [ __ ] everyone's like
now i put i put money up on tank man
definitely gonna get killed
so it was like put they were betting
like stacks like ten thousand fifteen
thousand twenty i swear no no headgear
no hair no it was heavy
so but no no time limit so it's like no
rounds it's like dog house fight to the
death
right kind of thing but these are
prospects at the time so they were like
oh is money involved
oh turn the clock off everybody start
beating all that other stuff
floyd right there entertaining he's like
i put my money on tape right yeah we put
money in a tank
i'm gonna put money on tape right get in
the dog house
and man you're not gonna say devon beat
him
no he devin bro no he did it devin's
dead everyone
yeah for sure yeah okay yeah and
everyone who can it was there they can
confirm it
like yo devin put it on tank man
devin put it on tank devon's a real one
devin put it on tank though yeah i don't
know the story out there i swear to god
i swear to god how long did the
only person that had was filming was uh
you know elizabeth
they usually say camera's off too dirty
yeah but that's what i'm saying ely uh
that guy like elise set back how did
devon put it on him
hold on is this uh devin just like kept
body like bro tank was just
like in the corner yeah and he kept
holding him and he was like nah nah let
me let him go let him go until
the um one of the trainers got in the
ring tank wasn't landing
wasn't landing anything i'm talking
about no no no no early rounds like like
was that good bro listen the guy works
hard
tech like skill like the dude is i never
but again he won't do that in real life
in a real fight but he knows
but yeah he should just really show me
he showed me something yeah
and listen have you ever done the
doghouse thing hell yeah
hell yeah was so interesting something
like that my first yeah
they talk [ __ ] it's not that we do no
time in mma they call it the shark tank
so we're getting ready for a fight love
that [ __ ] like i stay in
and then there's a new guy every fresh
round so you go five rounds
you still get your minute break we go
five rounds and i stay in
and a new fresh fighter comes every
round are you serious are you talking
about
killers yeah wrestling killers no mma
mma mma
small gloves killers you don't get no
break no break
nah five rounds but hold on it was a and
you you knew you were gonna do it you'd
have like the worst [ __ ] anxiety
really i used to hate it and it was just
asleep so how many like what was it
it'd be like shane carwin rashad evans
cody donald
elliott just monsters and they're just
watching you
and by that fourth round you're
exhausted well how many days a week did
you do that
oh man just like once oh okay once
once a week once a camp once a camp once
again that is stressful
does it could be like wrestle until
someone's wear out did the next one come
in is that you don't do that they'll
break them yeah
in wrestling we used to do that you go
till some guy breaks oh okay
and how many times do you do that we do
that all the time oh okay gotcha
yeah so that's like y'all the version of
the dog yeah and you and you've done the
dog house yeah i was like this is so
stressful it's stressful yeah
i mean it was it was fun with your
friends it's a i love when i fought new
guys who was like new to the yeah
because all the homies that like they
talk [ __ ] and beat it yeah and when you
land a punch
it's like a rap battle you know how like
when a bar doesn't land
everything's embarrassing it's
embarrassing so it makes sense i did a
shark tank
getting ready for my i was doing the
shark tank getting ready for my ben
rothwell fight
and shane carl when he was the
heavyweight champ yeah came in the third
round
and two knocked straight up knocking me
out wait wait what
and then they like picked me back up and
i kept going and then like
my fight was the next weekend so i went
in that fight everyone's like oh you
barely got hits like yeah i got knocked
out the week before
[ __ ] wait hold on that's like with the
anthony joshua with the
andy ruiz what fight he got knocked out
sparring
you can't say nothing you can't be like
you know after the the post fight came
back oh well i got knocked out last week
you know
i [ __ ] up this no you just got to eat
it [ __ ] i said
now yeah this is my how about that when
i get off stage in the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler we got a [ __ ]
together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son